guys
I'm sorry that we're doing two
back-to-back almost not really because I
love it but
oh this is a God okay first off take a
dab because we have an intro song
oh yeah oh my gosh
I'm building in these little dab things
that we could do during the show now
[Music]
I love my mother
hate my brother
so let's get after it and have fun
[ __ ] bread
I love it every time well
um good news
not look first there's not many times in
history
where you have such a great
philosophical mind
no we're blessed to live in the same
time in history as Chris Cuomo I mean
honestly it must have been like living
in the same time as Socrates
or cool Modi
[Music]
[Laughter]
uh you're muted
um
yeah you just killed me with the Como do
you want to have the music that's okay
oh [ __ ] I love Fridays okay well listen
there's a lot of people bickering out
there about the Yi appearance on M4 is
everyone no one knows what's going on
but one man does
you've seen the Kanye crap all over the
internet right I told you you can't
censor anything these days they're gonna
find an outlet even if it's a three-hour
interview with Alex Jones he's
completely not being able to
yeah look I've always hey I've always
said you can't censor things that's
always been my stance always and forever
you don't be censor with people all
right
unless it's a story about your brother
sexually harassing women Ohana Biden's
laptop yeah exactly
or me having covered I like the way he
goes yeah like a three-hour interview
with Alex Jones like he says it all
derisively Alex has way more viewers
than you Alex Jones's interview is
bigger than anything you've ever done in
your entire career you [ __ ] entire
career Guido you you're your top moment
was the Q-tip with your brother it
really was and it's because you were a
joke
Kanye is merely a falling star who
thinks he can shock his way back to
relevance uh up high pot I'm the kettle
nice to meet you
I did a spit no I almost did a spit
thing are you [ __ ] he's talking he's
talking about himself
gonna shock his way back to Kanye was
very relevant until this meltdown yeah
falling star who thinks he can shock his
way back by the way it's falling star if
Kanye didn't see any new stuff and he
dropped another album it would have been
another humongous album it would have
been number one album so shut up back to
relevance
he's now relegated to a cautionary Tale
no matter how rich or talented or famous
someone is you can't take the [ __ ]
out of the [ __ ] if you know what I
mean you know what I mean huh you know
what you know
no one is immune from a diseased mindful
of no one is immune not even this
titsoon
that's mine
that's gonna be sold right next to his
free agency insurance
free agent shirts and then immune tits
own shirts just right next to each other
I got them in ladies cuts too
no one is immune from a diseased mind
full of malignant ideas
it doesn't hey hey Chris you look really
tired
doesn't he look really tired
that he doesn't get all the time by his
wife like are you ever gonna get that
settlement from CNN this podcast isn't
doing it he's wearing a shiny Robert De
Niro collection suit again too which is
my favorite it's all he owns this
[ __ ] tie is so shiny I can see my
reflection in it
how wrong he is for whatever reason
I believe that his problem is our
opportunity
because this is bigger than a man who
calls himself yay why did you interview
him then to whom we all can now say nay
yo he was [ __ ] proud of that bro he
looked in the mirror he [ __ ] sat
there in the mirror and he was like
honey honey honey honey honey what Chris
honey check this out what if I say
because this is bigger than a man who
calls himself yay to whom we all can now
say nay
is that is that it honey I gotta go take
the kids to karate also does anybody
notice he just had a [ __ ] guile
moment he said Canal you have a canal of
course Canal bro I can now go home I can
now go home imagine him waking up at 2
A.M in a cold sweat just going and then
grabbing a marker and getting the palm
of his hand and going yay
[Music]
no it's just dry pasta noodles no why
would he have boxed the noodles for an
emergency boil at night you never know
oh [ __ ]
we must you must as the core of this
country
okay
those of you thought all right Chris
really tired merch I don't want to get
back in Chris reel it he doesn't all of
you out there
okay should uh he's doing the fetterman
thing you know what's happening it's
like I think it's your right Mark she
doesn't have a producer industry like he
did at CNN like it's just a lot of just
let him keep talking I don't care we got
to fill 20 minutes concerned with the
game of Party politics who usually
leaves cable news Politics on his back
sometimes they get fired whatever we're
not really asking specific questions
here right get out my business I'm not
I'm not broadcasting a full name a bunch
of uh empty seats at an airport anymore
so I'm not really sure what to do with
myself I was gonna quit anyway
you're not about being left or right you
want reasonable this is now yours
you've never been reasonable Chris I
love this I love that he's reasonable
now
fight because it transcends right and
left and it's simply a matter of all
right I'm gonna bring on my workout
partner Mark highly Mark Carly good to
see you bud what's going on man God
his workout hard but it's probably
hardly passed your neck I [ __ ] know
now they don't they don't they only give
Pastor Nick to a-listers Como ain't
getting no Pastor Nick all right you
know that right come on guys guys come
on clean up the toys and stuff all right
my Jew personal trainers coming over in
a little bit
it's not about who's worse anymore
it is time that someone steps up and
decides to make our nation better and I
think I'm that man I think I'm demand
for the job
my time has come
step aside Andrew Ma's favorites gonna
take over now
oh [ __ ]
too many don't worry about it because
your brother Chris ain't gonna get in
trouble like you did because the broads
who blow me don't have buyer's remorse
you know what I'm saying
foreign
this is your uncle's funeral yeah they
like when I grab their titties not like
him
Andrew's standing there fuming just
fuming that is the mom's going like just
ignore him baby just just go pay your
respects
I can't my mama slap him right in his
mouth
taking cufflinks off
you two are tear in this family
Chris know you made your mother cry
you're happy with yourself
I don't know what to do anymore with
them
they're both taking off their [ __ ]
Rolexes they bought on Canal Street and
putting it in their pockets ready to
[ __ ] fist fight at their uncle's
funeral are you here all you here for
like 10 minutes is in in the silence is
heavy breathing and what sounds like
change in pockets as they take off every
piece of gold that they're wearing
to break it up and they're like oh
thank you your father hey what would he
think what would he think of this son oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] disgracias
but you're right the old logo they'll go
slaps them both in the back of the head
what's the matter with you I have some
respect we're a week away from the Feast
of San Gennaro
this is so stupid and now you're ruining
it and now I'm not even looking forward
to myself release
[Laughter]
damn now I'm gonna put some good on the
stove
oh my God start the gravy now that's all
that's over she's just cooking in the
air
I'm worried about Ma
I'm so stupid
huh
okay sorry Chris what were you saying
I'm one minute into this [ __ ] video I
just want to point out with one minute
in
going Kanye's words across the internet
they're using it as click bait as if
there were no consequence to his words
and as wrong as that empty amplification
is the opposite instinct I don't believe
is a better outcome to censor to
de-platform all right listen fence
writing Chris Cuomo what do you believe
now because you've changed a lot hey
you can't send him a beanie yeah someone
get this guy a beanie balance things
these days I don't think it's right and
I don't think it's practical oh you're
gonna find complicated the way to a
digital diaspora wow he has a word of
the day calendar right like he does
because you notice he's late since he's
left specifically he's been dropping
like you know three dollar s.a.t words
every once in a while is there anything
worse than a guy who wants to be smarter
than he is no stop no
you're gonna find that again is there
anything funnier than a guy who thinks
he's smarter than he is no yeah see
that's the issue it's hilarious into a
digital diaspora
yeah that's right I was in my word of
the day calendar digital
it was obvious don't hide from it expose
it oppose it
and they're what was he rhyming now he
threw me a lot of rhyming lately there's
good news
when Alex Jones who've never heard of
the guy
that nut job excuse me
our friend Alex Jones you do not talk to
our friend Alex Jones that way all right
for real you hear that Alex Jones never
been fired he quits every place he works
at is uncomfortable like the alpha dog
he is comfortable with what someone is
spewing you know we have a consensus on
what must be opposed listen
here we go I'm Jewish people but I also
love Nazis
oh man well I have to disagree let's go
you're done here we go you're done with
that you're done with the family you're
dead take this money but never come back
here again
like Good Fellas I must turn my back to
you
as a matter of my choice not some
crowd-sourced consequence
but it's easy to take apart what he's
saying he's getting on his private jet
and he's like that was it three thousand
dollars and some shitty cookies for a
life
to all music plays always easy when it
comes to hate okay Hitler didn't invent
them you know it's weird too the Kanye
West cookie controversy like you know I
don't really ever eat like sweets right
and I just literally happen to buy a
cookie tray because I was shopping like
the day the Kanye thing happened and I
was like I was a little weird they're
like oh yeah and Kanye left with all the
cookies and I'm like oh I have cookies
always easy when it comes cookies hey
okay Hitler didn't invent the microphone
it was Christopher Columbus God Rest his
soul
no it's gonna be like uh you know it's
gonna be some other time it was Antoine
mittalucci that invented the microphone
it was actually Mussolini and then one
of these Jew folks stole it
now you can debate you know there were
evolutions of the technology how much
credit do we give David Edward Hughes
from England
uh how much credit do we give the Nazis
for the space program
Chris yeah I mean that's a little more
important than the microphone yeah I
mean literally you're you're by the way
Chris you're you're trying to sound smug
and intelligent while refuting points
made by a brain damaged [ __ ] black
man this is great but it's amazing but
he's also [ __ ] so it's like a [ __ ]
analyzing a [ __ ] and it's actually
really funny you know but him correlic
no obviously I mean you know I hate to
correct Kanye West here on his knowledge
of history but the Nazis did invent the
microphone thanks Chris you're smarter
than Kanye West congrats remember when
they tried to use our new word of the
year they tried to Gaslight us into
believing that black women doing math is
how we went to space and not because
Nazis
that was one of my favorite retelling of
histories that hidden figures movie
Emil Berliner Thomas Edis
but no he's pretending like he didn't
Wikipedia who invented the microphone
he's such a [ __ ] little phony right
he's pretending like hitting Wikipedia
and now he's repeating he's just
basically I guarantee you if you go to
the Wikipedia of the microphone he's
just literally reading a Verbatim he's
probably gonna start reading he's
probably gonna reference 255.4
Nazis need apply they didn't invent it
and Hitler didn't invent highways
he the Autobahn is a big deal I mean I
hear what you're saying he didn't invent
the highway
but he did make it better
so if you look up the history of
microphones the first thing that comes
up is a page that's the history of
microphones and the little paragraph
blurb was basically just what he said
dude he won't even go to the second page
of Google with his plagiar like you know
when you plagiarize something you go
like the fifth or sixth page of Google
hopefully they don't find you but he's
just the first result he's just
verbatimates it you're a [ __ ] boob
dude you're so stupid
actually I just read it here um Hitler
actually wrote Life is a Highway oh okay
oh
I say hi everybody
I want to cry it's all night long then
he was evil
roads were like back in Mesopotamia
they
no hold on
but a highway is when someone says
Highway they're now referring to the
roads in Mesopotamia you [ __ ] [ __ ]
he meant like vehicle Highway oh he
knows what he knows what he meant but I
also don't like this other thing that
we're supposed to pretend like the Nazis
didn't also invent cool things they did
invent cool things
I mean okay look there's a reason people
are still driving [ __ ] gtis and
Jettas you know what I mean
there's a reason Audi is coming because
cars because we all have great respect
for Hitler right no that's not I got mad
love for him that's not no that's not
enough Nazis
oh I don't have the face mask on
look I only met once that Mercedes-Benz
is a good vehicle that's it okay
like 4000 BC the first road to get a
code of tar how about that that wasn't
him it was the Sean silly Zay look at
him bro again Mercy nailed it a dumb guy
trying to act smart is so funny it's
funny and it's enraging at the same time
you know he has no idea what he's saying
at all
in Paris 18 20 something
America's first federally funded Highway
ran through six states completed in 1834
55 years before Hitler who was a failure
and a fraud he almost beat the world
and also nobody said like all right
Connie's again you're refuting Kanye
West misspeaking because he's a [ __ ] I
don't even think anybody would claim
that Hitler invented the highway nobody
you're putting words in people's mouth
yes he constructed the Autobahn
which was Germany's first major highway
but that that's still nobody's like wow
like nobody thinks Hitler was sitting
there and was like you know if a guy for
sinking what if we made the roads Vita
wow that's his correct idea
no but it's it's also the thing that he
was a fail he was just now look people
could be horrendous people but he's not
a failure that that's you know Hitler
pretty much almost invaded all of Europe
you couldn't keep your job at CNN did
you know that Germany went to war with
the world and get this they almost won
that's one of my favorite Norm Macdonald
jokes it's like dude they literally
almost invaded all of Europe he almost
became the ruler of the world and you
got out foxed by Don Lemon
yeah exactly so I wouldn't really [ __ ]
on him too much now yeah underachiever
fine I mean look that's the thing like
the the truth of the matter is it's
again you should know the norm thing
it's like wow it turns out it turns out
that only the good guys have ever won
any major war and it's true it's like
look it's a matter of [ __ ]
perspective it's just doing it saying
the [ __ ] about Hitler right
it's the same thing as like when people
go like well Thomas Edison what no
George Washington was wasn't actually a
great wasn't actually great because he
owned slaves you know it's using that
that one horrible thing takes away other
things like that's not the way it goes
look Gary Glitter is a pedophile but is
that a better hockey Banger at a game I
don't think so no he's still running hey
so you know
we're still sending that guy royalty
checks yeah in jail
was even born
you see
bigotry never stands up to scrutiny
it is rarely as much about the rational
as it is about a radical rejection of
decency in favor of perverse advantage
to make someone less so that you can how
many views you think this has
just so you know the downgrade that he's
I'm gonna guess if I had to guess
fifteen thousand five thousand oh
oh
ouch
wow that hurt my own
artificially ascend
and no matter where we find it
it can never be ignored because it will
be empowered
now look this is so much bigger than
just the idea of going after Trump and I
know that's happening but look
it is not right that Trump doesn't get
mentioned by name when his party is
forced to confront what is in their
ranks no no no no so you're saying again
I this is Trump's fault
oh it always comes back around to Trump
why is this Trump's fault
because they used free speech to stifle
Free Speech hey you interviewed him too
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
he's such a [ __ ] idiot he's not he
has 5 000 views I don't like punching
down on Chris Coleman would be honest
with you
at this point Chris we're punching down
yeah it's sad and I know you I know you
have a Google alert for your name
how the mighty have fallen see I want to
call him Mighty Men
um I guess I don't know you've seen them
back muscles
you see my lats my lats are pretty
Mighty yeah you know why I'm so strong
because I'm carrying the weight of my
brother's sexual assault allegations oh
a [ __ ] Atlas over here you
don't think that's strong you don't
think watch me pick up this rock hey hey
you looking I'm looking Chris we're
looking Chris will you see these traps
you see these trap muscles you know how
they got so big carrying water for the
Democrat Party
this farmer walks to do you good
he's doing the right side let's get
after it let's get after it